hey this is something really cool this
is I just like this okay we take calls
regularly now and we'll have some calls
on tomorrow's show the friday show we
have a voicemail number people can call
and sometimes people call there and
sometimes it will come to my attention
that somebody called in or left a
voicemail and then we used it on the
show and that person saw that we used it
on the show and they loved it and I want
to play for you just a little bit of a
video uh that a caller recently uh made
on YouTube and I don't know why I just
love the fact that he's so happy that he
was on the David Pakman show check this
out what you to its political monkey
here today to talk to you guys about my
debut on the david packard show me go
ahead leave a link right there never in
a million years that I think David
actually answer my question however I'm
very pleased that he actually has now my
question was regarding uh my previous
notion that the david pakman show was
actually affiliated with tyt which they
are no longer affiliated with tyt thank
jesus i love the david pakman show i
would be absolutely disappointed if the
show was infected with this sjw can't
yet so then he goes on to trash the
young turks and i have no interest in
that part whatsoever but hey this is
this that this is political monkey is
that the moniker uses on youtube I love
that someone was this excited about
getting their voicemail played on the
show a rather uh I believe this was a
voicemail not a live call it it's
absolutely fantastic we love having
audience voices on the show and that
this was very very cool to see of course
the voicemail number is available 24
hours a day that's 2192 david p the call
in number is different the call in
number is 6 17 8 30 for 750 and uh those
two numbers clearly making dreams come
true every day and that is just uh that
is absolutely just fantastic and the
live calls by the way have been going so
well we have basically will take calls
for 15-20 sometimes we can carve out as
much as twenty two or so min
it's on the friday show to take calls
and when we're done uh the calls just
keep coming in I mean the phones just
ring off the hook and we love hearing
from people so that is just absolutely
fantastic